joy this last week of summer it's gonna
feel like summer i can tell you that
we've got clear skies
but it is muggy out there we had
thunderstorms yesterday in the mountains
mount charleston picked up an inch of
rain again yesterday and then over the
weekend
various sides of town got hit west side
had it on saturday
the northeast got clipped with some
storms yesterday so yeah they were
popping up all right
we've got a lot of 80s so we've got
muggy air
still out there and a very slight chance
of mountain thunderstorms again
this afternoon and then we'll start to
really dry out
high pressure will settle in and that is
going to get those temperatures
way above normal for our first week of
august in fact
near record highs by the middle of the
week we'll start drying out that high
pressure will
again cap off that monsoon moisture
we'll still see a
slight chance of thunderstorms again in
maybe lincoln county otherwise central
nevada and over in northwest arizona
by the middle of the week we've got heat
watches that we have to worry about
which
might turn into heat warnings and could
last actually more than just a day right
now they're just issued for wednesday
i have a feeling they'll extend them
into thursday the national weather
service
80 degrees at the mountain today slight
chance of thunderstorms again could be
some
brief heavy downpours lightning and
gusty winds
105 for the valley and the closer you
are to the mountains
is the foothill areas might get in on a
little bit of rain as well and then and
then we're done we're looking at a very
hot week
105 today 108 tuesday 110
for wednesday and thursday those are
going to be the toughest days
valley neighborhoods so we'll be in the
one teens and then we'll back off on the
heat a little bit
as we get to the weekend back down to
104 so a hot summer week for us as we
head into august